welcome to this video playing mr.
Yardbird game 42 of this eternal battle
I'm down three games 19 losses 16 wins
it's not playing okay slide slight delay
too because I have to get my coffee
delay he's playing more before lately
not sure why I want a nice Kings Indian
against him some time ago play the the
brea variation which somebody requested
that's a very very decent life but um I
also had one very bad position recently
where someone got in before night be 395
that was very I was very uncomfortable I
don't really know the opening well so
okay might also have see for them i
wonder if i should actually provoke a
five maybe c4 yes he plays civ form
can I can I take twice place if I if
that that would that will sharpen up the
position enormously can also take deform
not sure and that let's check there
maybe you can take on each five that's
interesting it interesting idea de5 cd3
takes on f6 hmm ok did not go for it so
let's take here and then c5 that was
that was the idea position gets opened
up quite quite quickly ok so he wants to
take ok I have to take on interesting I
don't have to take with the pond I can
also think about taking you for here
I'll caddy zigzags ok I'll check here
and let's let's do it come on yeah
Knight takes and then e 5 is a move
in the night ii 595 and possible
sacrifices are happening
that's not easy okay I'm not sure what
I'm thinking I have to take anyway I was
a stupid idea I just have to play ok 95
he's got this this Bishop h7 business
takes takes at the end Queen age 50
remarkable ok so let's see if I can take
and play 97 get rid of the dangerous
annoyed Bowie it really dangerous anyway
this position I'm not threatening the e5
pawn because of the hanging a drogue now
white is better why it is very much
better
now I don't know the brayer yet I get
really that Elsa troubling position this
might be three a-five possibility always
some hmm kind of rotates me I had to add
this in an earlier game when the night
coming to a 5 was very am very
problematic okay it's not moving there
are quite some possibilities there like
a queen f5 24 for the mating ideas Queen
g3 e6 is also an interesting move I have
to take with the pawn which looks kind
of ugly but i'm not sure that i believe
in his six very much yeah he goes for it
maybe he has a very concrete way to
justify the move I wire oh wait I can
also play Knight to f6 rabbit why not
take it if it plays this yeah i have 9 f
six hours thinking just trading trying
to trade and whoops is 60
Chucky all right I see up for some
tactic look be 640 p 7
yeah look a seven looks ugly but i don't
i don't see a movie at the mode
that sucks I don't see move at the
moment that's very very uncomfortable
position the thinking of maybe getting
the Queen to deform rupee seven takes
takes Queen come in the form I can also
check him there King edge to its not
leading too much the Queen looks active
may I can generate some kind of player
it looks very ugly on the dark squares
but g5 was was an irritating move okay I
cannot play time morning maybe I can get
the rook on f7 from accounting play
against f2 after I have to find check
some kind of play okay let's not let's
not so bad maybe night to a forum all of
a sudden so I can check him check check
and now I'm taking here and have to us
hanging check so check there check
whereas the maid is there checkmate I
don't see a check made we should be
seven kings veil
I don't see a medic ok I have to move
we should be sound and then some we look
at five check check you got five check
that's killing Ruger fine check takes
Queen g5 mate kingi 655 made yes Wow I
completely slide through this window of
myself out of that or he swindled
himself out of it Wow now I was service
I was busted here simply he outplayed me
yeah that I don't know this is kind of
thing in the opening okay I went there
computer wants to check with the night
that's ugly I have it maybe maybe Bishop
f6 is maybe not let that grade I have a
hard time to believe it this is the
computer variation with a slight edge
for white that looks darn ugly when the
evaluation is climbing up this pawn
structure is just terrible okay but this
is definitely this is definitely very
very very dangerous I took Bishop f5 is
winning straight winning okay because is
six is a very strong threat or queen d 5
so let's say look here Queen d5 and now
he's threatening even this move wow this
is the line that the comp is killing
this and 96 bishop t6 t6 and I'm busted
yeah and I knew that something was here
I mean this also is good for white of
course
yeah kind of barely hanging on but yeah
g 4 i'm not sure about if you want to
play that that's probably good compound
supply rook a seven but a g4 is probably
not a bad idea here cheeks i went here
just for this one was trick of this
check one possible 95 but Queen a five
wins because I cannot move the night due
to made no now Buster TMS was just a
very lucky swindle check and here if he
goes to age 2 is still wins still wins
that's the winning there no no I'm
winning takes takes check Quinn Eve one
is winning now chap at the hope now that
said also wins but maybe not with my
move I didn't find a win here Q in h1
wins don't ask me why I am threatens
Bishop e7 okay i went back which is I
just had to play a move right I didn't
see a move so I had to play one key King
age five is the computer with equal
equal honey yeah I don't know what I
would have done here have a queen f2 or
something I don't know compounds to play
Queen d4 I mean we have your own equal
material yeah that's funny it's not that
I would sacrifice something which is got
the a porn queen before computer gives
equal maybe we trade everything there I
probably would have played something
like that not if
it's tricky i mean yeah this is a check
funny funny end to the game okay I that
was entertaining thanks for watching